-Guys, some entertainment news.
A lot of fans are theorizing that Beyoncé
has a new album coming soon because of mysterious clues
that she dropped online this weekend.
-Yeah, but how do you know for sure?
Isn't that just a rumor?
-I mean, the clues are everywhere, Tariq.
-Like what? -Okay.
So, on Friday, Beyoncé deleted her profile pictures
for all her social-media accounts --
Twitter, Instagram, TikTok, all of them.
And she still hasn't uploaded new ones over 72 hours later.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Go on.
-Beyoncé's most recent studio album was "Lemonade,"
which was surprise released over six years ago in 2016.
But you know what else happened in 2016?
Her second Super Bowl performance, the one with Coldplay.
And we all know what happened the day before that performance.
She surprise released the song for the video "Formation."
Then immediately after the Super Bowl, the next day,
she announced The Formation World Tour all before
anyone even knew that she was going to surprise release
"Lemonade" that April!
-Well, that was 2016, though.
-Right, right, right, but both "Lemonade"
and her self-titled surprise album, "Beyoncé,"
had sneaky clues before the release, too,
like Beyoncé posting pictures of herself with lemons.
And on Saturday, fans realized
that if you search Saturday's date, June 11th,
on Beyoncé website, placeholder art
for a mysterious Beyoncé album
that's just called "B7" came up.
"B7." Beyoncé's seventh album. Get it?
[ Audience oohs ]
-But she didn't release an album this weekend.
-Are you even listening? 'Cause then Tidal,
the streaming service that Jay-Z is on the board of,
tweeted, "What is a B7?"
Then just "B8." Jay-Z is Beyoncé's husband.
So, if and when Beyoncé puts out a new album,
it could be "B7" and "B8."
That's a double album. Isn't that crazy?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, it's crazy alright.
Crazy in love!
[ Roots play "Crazy in Love" ]
♪♪
Alright.